were you naturally a people person
before you got into entrepreneurship I
think so I was fraternity president when
I was I was going to ask if you're a
fraternity president I swear to God
anybody who is not in that world assume
that it's like Chief partyer and it's
like not that you like the guy that has
to be able to be respected enough when
he says like I'm pulling away the punch
bow like the cops are here or the guy
who has to talk to the cops you want
that guy who's going to have the
conversation who's going to like
negotiate on your behalf with Vanderbilt
with like how much trouble you're going
to be in because you brought Liquor on
campus and you're not supposed to you
get the prestige cuz of the title but
the actual day-to-day is like do we have
enough cups do we have ice do we have
speakers